-Our first guest tonight is an
Emmy- and Golden Globe-winning
comedian you know from his work
on "Saturday Night Live,"
"Brooklyn Nine-Nine,"
"Palm Springs,"
and is one third of
The Lonely Island.
All six episodes of his show
"Baking It"
will be available to stream
December 2nd on Peacock.
Let's take a look.
-I could not be left alone
with this cake.
[ Laughter ]
-No, no. No.
-Because I know what I do
with king cakes at home
during Mardi Gras carnival.
-We don't.
[ Laughter ]
-I mean, I can't stop eating it.
-Oh. Right, right, right.
-Whoa, what --
what were you thinking?
-I --
-What?
-Do you --
-Huh?
-He was worried
that the cake was going to get
too handsy with you.
[ Laughter ]
-[ Laughs ]
Please welcome back to the show
the best in the biz,
our very good friend,
Andy Samberg!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yes.
-Hello!
-What's up, dude?
Can you hear me?
-Now, so, you also play
all the grandmothers
in that clip, yes?
-Yeah. It's a "Klumps."
I "Klumpsed" it.
[ Laughter ]
-So, "Baking It" is very much
in line --
maybe even a spinoff
you would call it?
I know you love the term
"spinoff" --
of Nick Offerman and
Amy Poehler's "Making It."
-Yes, it is an extension
of the "Making It" world.
Amy is the producer of the show.
-How did she get you to do it?
-Well, it was a funny story.
She called me.
And I was like, "Hey, Amy,
how's it doing?"
And she was like, "Hey! Hey!
You're gonna do a show!
A baking show!"
And I was like,
"Oh, okay. I'm sorry."
And she was like, "Shut up,
I made you! I made you!"
And I was like, "Okay, I'll do
it. I'll do it. I'll do it."
You know how Amy is.
-Yeah.
I mean, I would say if she has a
catch phrase, it's "I made you."
-"I made you."
[ Laughter ]
-You -- So, the first episode
is Hanukkah themed.
Was that your idea?
-No.
It was actually the show's idea
and, you know, they came to me.
I think it was maybe Amy's way
of smoothing things over with me
for yelling at me.
-Yeah. Yeah.
-But it was interesting, because
she was like,
"Hey, one of the first bakes
we're gonna have
in the competition
is gonna be Hanukkah themed."
And I remember my response.
I said, "Your funeral."
[ Laughter ]
You know?
So I mean, I immediately assumed
everyone was just going to make
cakes in the shape of the socks
they were given for Hanukkah.
-Right. [ Laughs ]
Was that a big Hanukkah gift
for you? Socks?
-Oh, yeah. I'd be like, "Socks?"
And they'd be like,
"No, but these are special
because they're fleece socks."
[ Laughter ]
-Were you excited as a young man
when you got fleece socks?
-I was stoked.
I was like, "Now I have
something to wear
with my Tevas."
-Right.
-And you know what?
I have to say, Seth.
-Uh-huh?
-I wore Tevas and fleece socks
often in high school
and a little in college...
and a little out of college...
-[ Chuckles ]
-...and I got reamed for it,
you know?
I got bagged on, dunked on,
the gamut.
Then a couple years ago,
all of a sudden
it's like ironically cool
to wear fleece socks with Tevas.
I see my man Jonah strolling
down the promenade
being called a fashion icon
for it.
[ Laughter ]
I don't know.
I just feel like either
I'm old...
or I'm super old.
-[ Laughs ]
-Now, it was lovely the to see
you with all those grannies.
Four grannies. Are the four
grannies always the judges?
-They are, yeah.
It's one of the main things
I love about the show.
It's very warm and cozy.
The grannies are the judges.
Even when
they're being critical,
they're very supportive.
It's for the holidays.
It's a nice cozy, you know,
warm blanket of a show
and it's really like family
show, you know.
And it's really like a family
show, you know?
-Yeah, and it's nice.
It's on Peacock,
-It's nice. It's a family show,
but it's on Peacock.
Which I believe the title of the
streamer, Peacock,
is actually TV-MA.
-How so?
-Well, just, you know, 'cause
the word peacock.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, but it's --
it's the bird.
-Like the bird?
-No.
-Not the bird?
Not the bird?
-No.
[ Laughter ]
Do you think
they should have chosen
something else
other than Peacock?
-I mean, I heard it was between
that and Comcast Nards.
[ Laughter ]
-They were going to call it
Comcast Nards?
-Yeah, but I mean, it was
keeping in the tradition.
'Cause you probably don't know
this, but NBC actually stands
for Nards...
-[ Laughs ]
-...Boobs...
and Crack, but not the drug.
Butt crack.
-I feel like you maybe forgot
halfway through
what all those things...
You said it real slow
like you were remembering.
-Yeah, Seth, it's hard to tell.
Am I killing in the studio?
-[ Laughs ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Is the timing right?
-I think -- I have one issue.
I feel like you made that up.
And can I tell you why I think
you made that up?
-Please do.
-You're the only human being
I've met in the last 20 years
who uses "nards."
-Right. Right.
-[ Laughs ]
-That's fair.
-Do you think nards
is going to come back
like fleece socks and Tevas?
-With Tevas?
[ Laughter ]
-Nards is gonna be like
what cool kids call
a guy cool enough
to wear fleece socks and Tevas.
They'll be like,
"That guy's the nards."
-It's like owning trash culture,
you know?
It's like, "Nards,
but it's sexy now."
You're just like, "No."
Well, maybe. I don't know.
As I mentioned, I'm old.
Is it killing?
Are we killing in the studio?
-I've got a lot more to ask you.
We'll be right back with more
Andy Samberg after this.